well the former acting homeland security
secretary chad wolfe joins us now he is
also a visiting fellow at the heritage
foundation uh you had the job of of
trying to ensure among other things that
the border is secure in this country as
you look at what the biden
administration is doing what's your
reaction
well they're not doing much uh
unfortunately we still have the worst
border crisis that we've seen in our
lifetimes and really ever along that
border and so they're not talking about
new policies they're not talking about
new enforcement actions along that
border to try to curb some of this
illegal apprehensions that we see
instead instead it's just more of the
same so over 2 million illegal
apprehensions last calendar year
we see that number continuing the
reporting uh from bill uh indicates as
much it continues to be a very busy
place along that border in the rio
grande valley because we know uh that
the biden administration is not serious
about upholding the rule of law and
actually enforcing uh border security
yeah let's take a look at the numbers
fiscal year 2021 versus 2022 uh the
number of uh
southwest border encounters they call it
218 000 in 2021 this is just the first
quarter
in 2022 the first quarter 518 000 that's
up 138
uh this crisis shows no sign of abating
chat
yeah absolutely not it will continue
this is again i think it's important to
remember though that this is a
self-inflicted crisis it didn't need to
occur the border was uh under control at
the end of the trump administration we
had given them a playbook to continue
some of those uh
procedures and policies they chose not
to and so they have created this crisis
that we see over the last 12 months but
they don't seem to be interested in
solving it every time we hear the dhs
secretary talk he talks about they have
a plan and they're executing the plan
and so i have to say that this is what
they
are choosing to do
with border security is basically erode
it destroy it and you see the the catch
and release policies uh failed catch and
release policies every day well at his
inauguration president biden put his
hand on a bible and swore to faithfully
uphold and and defend the laws of the
united states it is illegal to come
across the southern border why does the
president
not seem interested in in defending the
border
it's a great question and i think you
know we we see border patrol really at
their wits in uh there was leaked video
a week or so ago them confronting the
secretary saying you need to do your job
let us do our job because they're
handcuffing the border patrol and
they're not able to apprehend
individuals some of the gang members
that bill talked about it at the
beginning of the segment we know those
individuals are crossing the border but
when you don't let border patrol do
their job and you don't provide them
leadership which the bite administration
is not doing then basically you're
saying it's open season and everyone can
come across that border and that's why
we are seeing historic numbers and if
you remember they tried to justify it
saying it was first it was the trump
administration's fault then it was
seasonal and then it was cyclical uh
they refused to actually say why it's
occurring which is because they have
torn down policies and have chosen not
to replace them with anything that is
meaningful in any any measure well and
then there's the drug smuggling let's
take a look at some of the numbers on
fentanyl
seizures in this country twenty eight
hundred and four pounds seized in fiscal
year uh 2019
it roughly doubled 4 791 pounds in
fiscal year 2020 11
200 pounds in fiscal year 21
and in just the first quarter of uh 22
2707
pounds of fentanyl have been seized is
it any wonder that fentanyl overdose
deaths have reached have skyrocketed
really to the worst ever in this country
unfortunately it's not i think if you go
back to 2018 and 2019 in the trump
administration we took certain measures
to stop some of that fentanyl coming in
from china which is where the majority
of this originates from through express
consignment such as ups and fedex and
dhl and because we did that
those uh that fentanyl is now going to
mexico and then through our southern
border the bight administration knows
this
but what we see down there with the
human smuggling is the cartels are
making millions of dollars every day and
they're able to put those proceeds back
into the illegal narcotics and smuggle
more and more across that border every
day which is going into communities
killing americans every day and so when
we talk about the border crisis it's not
just a crisis of individuals coming
across but it's also in the card
illegal narcotics the two are tied
together you can't talk to about one
without addressing the other
and again this administration is not
interested really in addressing either
yeah it would be good to see the
president or maybe his vice president
addressing the problem former acting dhs
secretary chad wolfe thanks very much
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else